[Music]
thank you is a history professor at
Georgia Gwinnett college outside Atlanta
he's exactly the kind of immigrant we
would want in this country he's educated
he knows English well and he cares a lot
about what's best for the United States
his new country but professors you was
also a vocal critic of illegal
immigration and for that he has been
attacked it's a thought crime some are
calling for him to be fired one lawmaker
in Georgia even voiced plans to write to
his college to voice or quote concerns
in our Wellington firm professor Zhu
says he won't back down though and he
joins us tonight professor thanks very
much for coming on thank you for having
me
well first of all I'm an associate
professor with job security my
institution has an academic freedom
policy I teach students the difference
between legal and illegal immigration so
lumping legal and illegal immigration
together is not only wrong it's deeply
offensive it's like lumping pharmacists
and drug dealers together and calling an
illegal immigrant a quote undocumented
immigrant is like calling a drug dealer
quote an unlicensed pharmacist or a
student who intentionally cheated on a
test a quote answer key borrower okay so
what you know if I had a professor like
you in college I probably would have
learned something and enjoyed it what
are your kids say what are your students
say when you peel off a line like that
well most of my students are against
illegal immigration I respect everyone's
viewpoints I tell students you don't
have to believe me if you want to make a
convincing argument please provide
evidence do you provide evidence to back
up your positions on immigration
absolutely there have been numerous
studies Harvard professor George Boras
had conducted the most in-depth
statistical analysis on the negative
consequences of illegal immigration on
the American economy and how that
directly lowers the incomes of high
school graduates those with less than a
high school diploma in the United States
yes so for the saying what you just said
backing up and it
opinion with evidence in this case by a
Harvard researcher some are saying that
you should be fired from your job what
does that tell you well first first of
all I have job security I'm an associate
professor my institution has an academic
freedom policy my perspective is
everyone's entitled to their opinions I
don't know this lawmaker she doesn't
represent me I've never met her she can
say whatever she wants so she can
contact my institution apparently she
has some Pro illegal immigration
followers I've gotten a lots and lots of
messages most of them are overwhelmingly
supportive I have a few that disagree
with my views but I respect everyone's
opinions everyone has the right to free
speech what first of all I just want to
say again I'm so glad that you moved to
this country I admire your bravery I
can't believe there's someone like you
still teaching in a in an American
University what are your colleagues
think of you well I think most of my
colleagues know my anti-illegal
immigration activism and they understand
my perspective as a legal immigrant and
I feel like my colleagues respect my
views and I respect their views do you
really think they respect your view I
hope you're right so when you move to
this country and they told you that we
had free speech here you took that very
seriously I can tell well here's what
I'll say I always vote in every single
election I'm a proud Georgia Republican
I vote in the Republican primary and I'm
gonna work as hard as I can to help my
friend congresswoman karen handel here
reelected in 2020 in the Georgia 6th
district do you think your colleagues
are ok with that - well it doesn't
matter what their opinions are I respect
their views some of them live in my
district some of them don't
I assume more of them are liberal some
might be moderate but at the at the same
time I respect their views and they
understand where I'm coming from and I
think they respect my views do you think
the Democratic Party wants more
immigrants like you well I don't know
but I'll tell you this in other
countries I can
they have a merit-based point system
where they give priority the
well-educated legal immigrants who have
college degrees who can speak English
and who have job skills that are needed
no country on earth has 12 million
illegal immigrants and give birthright
citizenship to the children of illegal
immigrants I'm for any program that
admits more people like you into this
into this country but wouldn't you think
that Democrats would be happy to have
you I mean if they're pro-immigrant I
imagine you must be getting calls from
Democratic lawmakers just thanking you
for expressing your opinion have you
well well I'm a Republican
but I respect a lot of Democratic
lawmakers so I think that for one thing
is the United States has 12 million
illegal immigrants no other country on
earth has 12 million illegal immigrants
and gives birthright citizenship to the
children of illegal immigrants so if you
look at Canada you look at Australia
they have a merit-based immigration
system that gives priority to those with
college degrees English speaking skills
and job skills that can contribute to
their economy so they have very few
illegal immigrants of course if you
cared about your country that would
difficult of course you'd have a system
like that it wouldn't even be a question
professor thank you you're welcome on
this show any time it's great to have
you tonight thank you thank you for
inviting me